So, da sind wir wieder.
Ich musste den Server wechseln, auf den ich streame.
Jetzt sollte es wieder alles funktionieren.
Wo davon ist auch richtiger Schrott?
So, wo sind wir gerade stehen geblieben?
Ich habe mich gerade aufgeregt über Helpline, korrekt?
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben, Leute?
Ich glaube, Helpline.
Ja, ich habe gesagt, du kennst das.
Du kennst das.
Wenn du das kennst, wirst du wahrscheinlich auch wissen, wie kacke Helpline ist.
Und ganz ehrlich, Leute, guckt euch dieses Ding an.
Wobei, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, welches.
Grausam, grausam, grausam, ja.
Und ohne Scheiß, Leute, Helpline ist das räudigste Ticketsystem.
Und das schlechteste und nervigste Ticketsystem, was ich jemals gesehen habe.
Richtiger, richtiger Schrott, Sgt. Silver.
Richtiger Schrott.
Sag mal, ich habe mal eine Frage, Sgt. Silver.
Haben wir mal Battlefield gegeneinander gespielt?
Oder zusammen, oder so?
Nein?
Moment.
Ich hatte doch mal irgendeinen Clip hochgeladen, bei mir auf dem damals Zweit-Zweit-Channel,
wo ich manchmal Battlefield-Zeug hochgeladen habe, vor acht Jahren.
Und jetzt weiß ich nicht, wo.
Da hieß doch auch einer irgendwie Sgt. Silver oder sowas.
Ja, gut.
Wie das Video einfach 214.000 Aufruf hat.
Gut, gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal weiter.
Ich bin ja wieder etwas sidetracked worden.
Helpline Classic, ja, so hieß das.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, so hieß das.
Ich glaube, so hieß das.
Ah, ja, ja, perfekt.
Ja, ja, das ist es.
Das ist es.
Was ist denn das für ein Kack?
Monkeys.
Es ist immer noch ein Kack-PDF, Mann.
Das ist es.
Das ist das Ticketsystem, Leute.
Das ist so ätzend.
Das ist so dermaßen schrottig, Alter.
Ja.
Gucken wir mal in das PDF rein hier.
Ich dachte eigentlich, dass Chrome...
Kannst du ja auch.
Guckt euch das an.
Windows.
Windows only.
Du musst das administrieren.
Okay, nice.
Das ist so schrottig, Alter.
Das ist ohne Scheiß das ätzendste und schlimmste Ticketsystem, mit dem ich jemals machen musste.
Guckt euch...
Ich meine, guckt euch allein schon mal die Oberfläche an, da wisst ihr schon Bescheid, oder?
Wenn ich das schon sehe.
Naja, gut.
Ja, nice.
Willst du sagen, dass Parkside schrott ist?
Parkside ist Lidl.
Parkside ist, wenn man sich Refuse anguckt, gar nicht so schlimm.
Ich habe gesündigt.
Sowieso, was hast du gemacht?
So viel Buber.
Was, was hast du gemacht?
Was hast du getrieben?
Also, ganz ehrlich, wenn das 40 Jahre überlebt hat, dann ist es wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut Qualität.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich Arch use, by the way, aber dabei benutze ich Manjaro.
Chat.
Was sagt ihr dazu?
Icos benutzt Manjaro und dann sagt, dass er Arch benutzt.
Also, das können wir nicht durchgehen lassen.
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, wie da ein geeignetes Punishment für aussieht.
Ich würde sagen, vielleicht, vielleicht irgendwas in C++ programmieren oder so.
Wie kann ich das wieder gut machen?
Ja, ich überlege mir noch was.
Ich, ich überlege, ich überlege mir noch was.
Vielleicht, vielleicht eine Präsentation über C++23 Features.
Oder eine Woche mit der Bahn fahren, ja.
Weiß ich gar nicht, was da mehr.
Wobei Bahn fahren, wenn sie fährt, ja gar kein Problem ist.
Zahmat kenne ich nicht.
Soundticketsystem?
Zahmat, Helpdesk.
Ich bin immer wieder begeistert, wie viele es von diesen Systemen gibt.
Was ist eigentlich, das ist Jira.
Was ist eigentlich die Daseinsberechtigung von 500 verschiedenen Ticketsystemen, Helpdesk-Systemen, Knowledgebase-Systemen?
Ich, ich, ich würde, ich würde sagen, ganz ehrlich, warum, warum kann man nicht einfach Jira und Doku-Wiki oder sowas verwenden?
Hast du schon mal Semaphore benutzt?
Also, falls es ein Ticketsystem gibt, was so heißt, nein, dann nicht.
Wenn du ein Proggers-Stells geht, dann schon.
Weil Jira Schrott ist, echt?
Warum?
Also, ich muss sagen, eigentlich finde ich bisher Jira mit das angenehmste Ticketsystem.
Du, du, du, du, du.
Das kann ja keine E-Mails richtig darstellen, was, jo, okay.
Dann, dann, dann verstehe ich, ja, dann hast du andere Anforderungen an das Ticketsystem als ich.
Das, das hatte ich, das hatte ich noch nicht.
Ich überlege gerade, was wir damals beim Provider für ein Ticketsystem haben, hatten, hatten.
Wie gibt es, also, weder haben, weil ich nicht mehr dabei bin, noch haben, weil den Laden gibt es nicht mehr.
Der ist pleite.
Ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt.
Es war nicht Jira, das ist viel zu lang, viel zu alt, da gab es noch kein Jira.
Das war 2007.
2007 bis 2011 oder so war ich da.
Aber, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie das Ticketsystem hieß.
Aus Doku und To-Do-Liste zum Beispiel.
Ach so, wie wäre es mit Doku-Wiki, wenn einfach sonst nichts geht?
Und das Schöne an Doku-Wiki ist auch noch, dass es Plaintext ist.
Wie gesagt, ich finde Jira gar nicht so übel.
Also, wenn man es nicht komplett misshandelt mit irgendwelchen komischen Plugins, dass nichts mehr übrig ist vom ursprünglichen Ding.
Ich finde Jira auch noch, die Box ist echt okay.
Wenn man das halt für Soft-, als Ticketsystem für Softwareentwicklung macht.
Wenn man es zweckentfremdet, ist jedes System und jedes Tool Kacke.
Okay, das klingt nicht so geil.
Ja.
Wir haben gestern C++ gemacht, Advent of Code.
Allerdings habe ich Rage quittet, weil ich die Sprache nicht mehr ertragen habe.
Object Storage...
Okay, was willst du machen genau?
Weil...
Die haben ja einige...
Die haben ja einige Features nachgerüstet in den letzten Versionen.
Die haben ja mittlerweile auch beispielsweise eine Container Registry und sowas dabei.
Was ich sehr nice finde, ehrlich gesagt.
NWU allein habe ich noch nicht benutzt.
Oh, sad girl.
Feels bad man.
Ja, da hast du wahrscheinlich Glück.
Ist nicht so viel passiert.
Remedy habe ich auch schon mal gehört.
Aber das hatten wir beim Provider nicht.
Das war...
Vielleicht war das sogar irgendwas Selbstgestricktes.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr, wie das hieß.
Bookstack basiert nicht auf Plaintext, sondern auf einer Datenbank.
Deswegen mag ich das nicht so.
Ja, aber wahrscheinlich läuft das da auch seit 2008.
Ja, hast schon recht.
Hast schon recht.
Ich...
Ich würde zwischen...
Ich hätte da jetzt gar keinen Unterschied dazwischen gemacht.
Aber es ist eindeutig darauf ausgelegt.
Ja, das merkt man auch schon an den ganzen Presets.
Also, dass das...
Vielleicht jetzt bei einer Hotline zum Beispiel nicht gut passt als...
Als...
Problem-Tracking-Geschichte und sowas.
Kann ich mir vorstellen, ja.
Übrigens.
Wisst ihr, was ich gesehen habe?
Das müssen wir auch noch mal demnächst im Stream ausprobieren.
Der Typ, der Uptime Kuma programmiert hat, das ist...
Das will ich euch gar nicht zeigen eigentlich.
Aber ich sag mal so für Leute, die es nicht kennen und daheim vielleicht irgendwie auf
dem Raspberry Pi oder auf dem kleinen x86 Server bei sich daheim Anwendungen betreiben.
Und überwachen wollen, ob die Systeme up oder down sind, ist das tatsächlich mit die
simpelste Monitoring-Software, die es gibt für den Heimbereich.
Auch super easy zu benutzen.
Natürlich nicht die großen Features wie beispielsweise jetzt Zabbix oder was mit Prometheus selbst
gestricktes oder Nagios oder Checkmk und...
Was habe ich noch vergessen?
Es gibt ja tausende Monitoring-Sachen.
Ichinga und...
Sensu und was auch immer.
Zumindest, wenn man einfach nur wissen will, Seite up, down, Server pink, nicht pink, ist
das net...
Na gut, net...
Netdata habe ich ehrlich gesagt noch nie jemand gesehen, der das wirklich verwendet.
Ja, aber da wollte ich gar nicht drauf aus.
Ich habe gesehen, dass der Luis...
Der Luis hat irgendwie ein neues Projekt am Start.
Genau, Docke.
Das ist...
Das könnte ohne Scheiß irgendein...
Das klingt wie ein Twitch-Emote, oder?
Docke.
Das ist ein fancy...
Easy-to-use-reactive-self-hosted-Docker-compose-stack-oriented-manager.
Klingt super kompliziert.
Letztendlich ist es ein Web-Interface, wo man Docker-Compose-Dateien anlegen kann.
So.
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass es so was wie Portena ist.
Zumindest nicht in dem Umfang.
Das wollte ich mir mal angucken.
Ich meine, ich habe keinen wirklichen Anwendungszweck dafür, ehrlich gesagt.
Also im Enterprise-Umfeld ähnlich.
Und selbst daheim auch nicht.
Aber ich finde es immer ganz gut, drüber auf dem Laufenden zu sein.
Was denn so alle Entwicklungen gibt.
Ja.
Ich sage doch, Docke klingt...
Also bei mir würde es Docker-Champ heißen.
Oder Dock-Champ.
Oder...
Oder so was.
Oder Container-Champ.
Proximox haben wir uns sogar schon im Stream angeschaut.
Ist für meinen Einsatzzweck nicht so das Wahre.
Aber...
nicht was für probleme hast du mit android gar keine man kann nicht wirklich sagen problem so
insgesamt bin ich einfach nicht so richtig glücklich damit ja dass sie als das web interface
wirkt ein bisschen wie vor zehn jahren entwickelt wenn es auch paar moderne ansätze hat wirkt das
teilweise doch schon doch schon ziemlich ziemlich alt backen manches braucht sehr lang bis es
geficktes die haben gefühlt ein halbes jahr gebraucht bis sie das gepasht haben dass die
verbindung zur zu docker habe wieder richtig funktioniert dass die dass die container nicht
dastehen als hätte jemand sein docker repo gelöscht haben die irgendwie fast ein halbes jahr für
gebrauchtes zu fixen manchmal bisschen langsam ich bin so ein bisschen blöd dass es auf slackware
basiert ehrlich gesagt andere sachen wären deutlich angenehmer da war es dann zu drehen
noch ja aber insgesamt ist es schon ja tun das habe ich mir angesehen hat mir gar nicht gefallen
ich glaube dass wenn ich das richtig zusammenkriege initial eindruck von schulers war eigentlich
ganz gut ich hatte auch eine weile in free nass im einsatz hier aber nachdem ich mir dann im detail
angeguckt habe war noch ziemlich viel an polis zumindest vor sagen wir mal im jahr oder so wo
wir uns das angeguckt haben ich mag die ganzen sachen nicht ich mag beispielsweise auch media
wollte nicht deswegen hatte ich ja lange zeit
einfach ganz simpel mit dem server stimmt nicht damals es war doch und server und das war noch
die zeit wo ich aus irgendwelchen gründen die ich mir heute nicht erklären kann immer noch gedacht
habe ubuntu server größer debian weiß auch nicht warum früher habe ich immer debian benutzt dann
habe ich irgendwann ubuntu server benutzt und jetzt benutze ich wieder debian weil ich überhaupt
kein grund mehr sehe für ubuntu server ich glaube ich bin damals umgeschwenkt von debian server also
von von debian auf also zu zeiten von ok jetzt bin ich wieder im server bin ich wieder im server
lasst mal überlegen leute kriegen wir wie viele debian version kriegen wir aus dem kopf hin leute
lasst mal überlegen wo die cert wurde ist ist es immer testing bukkow ist das neueste auf jeden fall
ja ja auf jeden fall opf warte mal ich muss mal in mich gehen warte mal wie es da wie es bulls auf
die Jeffers sind das kann ich die tageswahl das kann ich gar nicht beknüpfen kann ich nicht beknüpfen
weil ich muss einen sichtstrahl haben ich habe jetzt seit ca 10 tageswahl und der waschautag von krimtop und das kann ich einfach nicht mehr studieren
buchwurm ist das neueste edge edge ok auf jeden fall ja ja auf jeden fall edge ok, warte mal ich muss mal in mich gehen warte mal wie hieß der bulls auf den markt
Bullseye? Gab's noch Bullseye?
Buster. Buster ist der Hund, gell?
Moment, wie heißt der?
T-Rex aus
Toy Story?
Der heißt einfach nur Rex.
Rex gab es noch nie.
Warum gab es kein
Debian? Warum gab es
nie Debian Rex, Mann?
Ach doch, gab es, gab es.
Oh.
Debian Release
1997.
Fuck, Alter.
Hier ist Rex.
Okay, okay.
Lass mal in uns gehen. Also, was haben wir?
Woody, Sarge, Edge,
Jesse, Jesse,
Jesse, Buster,
Bullseye, Bookworm.
Mehr fallen mir nicht ein.
Sonst noch jemand? Ohne zu googeln.
Ja? Ohne zu googeln.
Och nee.
Nein.
Hier ist überhaupt nix F.
Hier ist nix F.
Ihr gebetet mich.
Ich hab noch nicht mal einen Frame.
Oh doch.
Ich hab, guck mal, ich hab keine...
Lenny?
Kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern.
Kann sich irgendjemand an Debian Lenny erinnern?
Das ist, das ist...
Nee, hier ist nix F.
Ihr habt die Aufzählung nicht mitbekommen.
Also, an die Debian Version, an die ich mich erinnern kann.
Äh.
Bookworm, Bullseye, Buster, Jesse, Edge, Woody, Tomato, sagt mir nix.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, Potato, weil ne Tomate, ne Tomate aus Toy Story fällt mir nicht ein.
Das muss wenn schon Potato gewesen sein, nicht Tomato.
Sarge.
Sarge gab's auch, genau.
Sarge war, glaub ich.
Das aller, allererste Debian, was ich verwende.
Ja, hab ich, hab ich, leider.
Sertge.
Das andere gibt's nicht.
Wart mal.
Debian Version...
Äh.
History?
Ja, aus irgendwelchen Gründen hab ich damals gedacht, äh, ich benutze...
Wahrscheinlich bin ich von Debian auf Ubuntu umgeschwenkt, weil die Packages ne Weile mal aktueller waren.
So in Zeiten, wo gefühlt alle Schaltjahre mal ein neues Debian rausgekommen ist.
Wobei, wenn man sich anguckt, im Prinzip ist das, ist die Release Schedule immer gleich, ja?
Gibt's so alle, alle zwei Jahre gibt's neues Debian.
Okay, also.
Das erste war Buzz.
Ja gut.
Das bietet sich auch, das bietet sich auch irgendwie an.
Ist ja eines mit der bekanntesten Charakter aus Toy Story.
Ich würde mal sagen Woody und Buzz.
Die, vom, vom ersten Toy Story an.
Rex?
Genau, da hätte ich auch mit gerechnet, dass der da...
Bo, ich hab keine Ahnung, wer Bo aus Toy Story ist.
Ach, Bo ist diese komische Puppe da.
Okay, ja, ja, ja.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ist das nicht die Freundin von Woody?
Toy Story Lore?
Kecke.
Ham?
Weiß nicht, wer das ist.
Slink?
Keiner.
Potato gab's?
Potato?
Woody, Sarge, Edge, Lenny.
Lenny?
Ich kann mich überhaupt nicht an Debian Lenny.
Leute, erinnert sich irgendjemand, das ist doch Fake News, oder?
Erinnert sich irgendjemand an Debian Lenny?
Vielleicht war das die Zeit, wo ich kein Debian mehr benutzt hab.
Okay, 2009, ey.
Wer, wer ist Lenny aus Toy Story?
Das zum...
Leute, ich hab noch nicht mal ne Ahnung, in welchem Toy Story das Ding überhaupt vorgekommen ist.
Also Lenny sagt mir gar nix.
Squeeze?
Wheezy?
Jessie?
Stretch?
Was bedeutet Orange?
Still main...
Okay, Buster.
Ja, gut, Buster ist ja noch nicht so alt, ja.
Buster?
Bullseye, Bookworm.
Trix, Trixie, Forky.
Ja, und Sid, Sid ist immer...
Sid ist immer...
Also quasi immer die, die Testing.
Die heißt, die hieß schon immer Sid.
Sid ist die, ist der Nachbarjunge, glaube, ne?
Sehen wir uns hin?
Jetzt haben wir uns super lang mit irgendwelchen Debian-Versionen auseinandergesetzt.
Hat ja überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Wie bin ich jetzt da überhaupt drauf gekommen?
Ubuntu, irgendwas.
Ja, ist auch.
Ich benutze es auch nicht mehr.
Michael5, dich hab ich ja voll übersehen.
Michael5Spilian ist auch nicht mehr da.
Ich bin doch wieder am Start.
Bist du noch da?
Schön, dass du auch mal wieder hier bist.
Pog.
Ganz übersehen.
Ich hoffe, du bist noch da.
In letzter Zeit.
Echt jetzt?
Ich hätte jetzt eher gedacht, du bist einfach gar nicht mehr so oft da.
Ich bin gerade überlegen, mein Notebook, das Windows 11 nicht supportet, auf Linux umzustellen, aber ich habe...
Hä?
Also ich, ich finde, ich finde, wenn man...
Noch, noch recht neu ist, was Linux angeht, dann kann man mit Linux Mint eigentlich gar nicht so viel falsch machen.
Ansonsten, ganz ehrlich.
Arch, by the way.
Also meine erste Debian-Version war, glaube ich, Sarge?
Woody habe ich tatsächlich nicht mitgekriegt.
Also meine erste Debian-Version war Sarge.
2000.
Aber nicht 2005.
Ich hab, ich hab Sarge benutzt.
Als Edge noch ganz knapp Testing war.
Also so irgendwie 2006 oder sowas.
Und Sarge, kann ich mich heute noch dran erinnern?
Die hatten noch kein X.Org, die hatten noch den X.Org-Vorgänger.
Sowas gab's tatsächlich auch mal, ja?
Heute ist ja X.Org schon outdated, overrated, jebaited.
Ich weiß gar nicht...
X3-86, genau.
Ja, das war's.
Genau, genau.
Mir wäre der Name wirklich nicht mehr eingefallen hier.
Und bei Edge war's dann X.Org.
Um mich zu jebaiten im Stream.
Oder machst du das wirklich?
Hi, ich hab mal eine Frage.
Ich kenn mich in Linux nur wenig mit Netzwerk-Config und allgemeinen Commands,
beziehungsweise Standard-Paketen aus.
Alles in Non-Desktop-Version.
Ja.
Das, da lernt man's auch am besten, ne?
Möchte jetzt etwas mehr in Linux einsteigen, bin absolut überfordert mit Desktop.
Gibt es da gute Startpunkte?
Also ganz ehrlich.
Ich mag keinen...
Also das ist meine persönliche Meinung, ja?
Ich mag keinen der normalen Linux-Desktops.
Aber zum Einstieg würde ich sagen, ist Linux Mint, Cinnamon wahrscheinlich ganz gut.
Das ist das, was ich den Leuten auch immer empfehle.
Du kannst dir das ja mal angucken, ob das was für dich ist.
Was mir persönlich am liebsten gefällt, ist das hier.
Nämlich gar kein richtiger Desktop, sondern einfach...
Ja, also Desktop gibt's ja hier gar nicht.
Ich hab keine Icons und nix.
Hier kannst du auch nicht klicken und keine Icons hinmachen.
Ich hab im Prinzip nur drei Desktops mit Fenster im Fullscreen.
Der Scheiß genau.
Ich hab im Prinzip hier nur drei Desktops, die ich durchschalten kann mit Hotkey.
Und ein nice Hintergrundbild.
Und das war's.
Also ich kann theoretisch bis neun Desktops durchschalten, aber ich hab meistens nur die ersten drei im Einsatz.
Ich hab prinzipiell nur Fenster im, äh, in der Regel meistens nur Fenster im Fullscreen.
Meistens nur Fenster im Fullscreen.
Sieht dann so aus.
Oder so aus.
Oder so.
Oder wie auch immer.
Und das Wichtigste hab ich auch am Start.
AskIquarium.
Aber das ist für nen Einstieg...
Achso, ja doch.
Ich kann theoretisch, wollt man grad sagen, ich kann theoretisch auch, ja, Fenster haben, die sich wie Fenster verhalten, aber keine Fensterrahmen und nix.
Alsoита?
Na klar.
Soowią ich.
Okay.
Also weiß ich normalerweise...
Nicht nur...
Ich bin auf Niederfl metric, nein?
Wow.
Ich bin acá...
Ich bin jetzt jag gider, keine siete Viertel!
Jawohl.
Gott sei gud.
steady never
Und mein brauchen nicht.
Ich hab jetzt noch vier Decker.
cannonsada겠어요...,
ja.
Und dann...
Das ist ganz, weiß man nicht.
Ja.